aquí tenemos 5 figuras tridimensionales
y también tenemos 5 nombres
y ahora quiero que pausa en el vídeo y
tratan de descubrir cuál de estas formas
corresponde a cada uno de estos nombres
cuál es una pirámide cuadrada cuál es un
prisma rectangular cuál es un prisma
triangular cuál es una esfera y cuál es
un cilindro resolvamos esto juntos esto
es algo importante de conocer porque en
futuros temas verán los nombres de estas
figuras primero veamos cuál es la
pirámide cuadrada esta forma de aquí a
la derecha claramente luce como una
pirámide y lo que lo hace una pirámide
cuadrada es la idea de que su base es un
cuadrado vamos a sombrear la la base de
esta forma es un cuadrado y por eso se
le llama pirámide cuadrada si fuera una
pirámide triangular entonces la base
tendría forma de triángulo pero esta es
una pirámide cuadrada así que vamos a
ponerle el nombre que le corresponde
hagamos el siguiente prisma rectangular
pueden ver a un prisma como un objeto
tridimensional y ya que dice prisma
rectangular la figura que tenemos aquí
que es rectangular es esta que tiene
rectángulos en cada uno de sus lados
representa tres dimensiones y es un
prisma así que este es el prisma
rectangular y vamos a ponerle su nombre
es el prisma rectangular veamos el
siguiente el prisma triangular este es
interesante si vemos esta forma de aquí
tiene lados que son triángulos este lado
es un triángulo y este lado de aquí
también es un triángulo aunque están
conectados por estos lados rectangulares
a esto se le llama prisma triangular
porque sus lados son triángulos en la
pirámide cuadrada los lados que son
triángulos se encuentran en un punto en
un prisma triangular tenemos dos lados
opuestos que son triángulos y esta
figura podemos encontrarla en diferentes
posiciones
algunas veces estará sobre este lado oa
veces estará sobre otro de sus lados
pero este es un prisma triangular así
que le ponemos su nombre nos quedan dos
más al de las figuras es una esfera
bueno cuando yo pienso en una esfera me
imagino una pelota y esto de aquí luce
como una esfera así que le ponemos su
nombre y finalmente esto que parece un
bote
un cilindro así que le ponemos su nombre
esto es un cilindro y hemos terminado
estos son nombres útiles para formas en
un cilindro tenemos dos lados que son
círculos y se encuentran opuestos entre
sí similar al prisma triangular sólo que
en lugar de tener estos lados
rectangulares debido a que los lados son
triángulos tendremos una base y una
parte superior que son círculos